Michael B. Jordan gained 24 pounds of pure
muscle in under a year. For us normal people,
that can sound like sorcery, but the real magic
is the Hollywood health plan he was following.
Take a look at Jordan's Instagram
pictures before his training intensified,
and you'll see that the actor has
never really been out of shape. Still,
it's a far cry from the shredded
frame he's had in more recent movies.
Everything changed with his casting as Adonis
Creed. Playing the son of "Rocky" opponent
Apollo Creed required him to look the part of
a boxer in peak condition. Even though Jordan
describes himself as a competitive athlete,
there's a different level of fitness required
for a boxer. According to trainer Corey
Calliet, it was hard-going at first, saying,
"When we first started, he
could barely bench 20 pounds,
his legs were flailing everywhere ... he
had nothing. He used to hate all this."
He might have hated the training,
but he can't hate the results,
since he put on 24 pounds
of muscle in just a year.
There's no easy shortcut for putting
on so much muscle in such a short time,
but a Hollywood trainer makes it a little
more manageable. Enter Calliet, a former boxer
whose experience was instrumental in crafting
Adonis Creed's physique. According to Jordan,
Calliet was the first trainer that he clicked
with after a series of false starts with others.
Calliet stayed with Jordan when he
got into a different type of fitness
for his role as Erik Killmonger
for the original "Black Panther."
Calliet played both sides of the movie's
conflict though. He also worked to get
Angela Bassett in fighting shape. Bassett
played Ramonda, the matriarch of Wakanda.
According to Calliet, whether he's training
someone in their twenties like Jordan or in
their fifties like Bassett, the technique
is the same. Focusing on high-intensity
interval training is the best way to burn
fat and highlight certain muscle groups.
To properly portray a boxer, Jordan had
to train like a boxer. That meant 45-60
minutes of cardio daily, along with tons
of ab workouts. As for building muscle,
Calliet had Jordan focus on supersets — exercises
where lifting or curling dumbbells are mixed with
push-ups or another workout. In addition,
Calliet pushed Jordan with circuit training,
building his endurance with quick
rounds of different cardio exercises.
"Yeah, that's cool, but you know, maybe
you could just give me some drills."
"Drills?"
"Yeah, you know, things I could do on my own."
If that all seems exhausting, we
haven't even gotten to the main event:
a full three hours of boxing training following
every workout day. In talking about the workout,
Calliet had this to say in an
interview for "Men's Journal":
"I wanted to make him look even more ripped
than Apollo, and I think we did that."
According to Jordan, his lifestyle
changed completely once he began to
see results from working out for
roles. About the change, he said,
"When things start getting a little easier, when
you start lifting weight you never lifted before…
Then it's, 'This is all right.' So I learned
to love it when I started seeing results."
Being in fighting shape from "Creed" helped
Jordan transition to the training for "Black
Panther," where he used a new technique
called "Muscle Training." The technique
adapted Jordan's workouts to match what
the character would do to stay in shape,
which helped alleviate the
dreaded workout plateau.
The first "Creed" established that Adonis was
fighting in the Light Heavyweight division,
which in boxing has an upper limit of 175
pounds. For the 2018 sequel "Creed II," however,
Jordan had to bulk up in order to fight Viktor
Drago, the fearsome son of Ivan Drago, played
by Florian Munteanu. For context, Ivan killed
Adonis' father in the ring three decades earlier.
The film gives Jordan an unconventional training
regimen. After losing to Drago in their first
bout, Adonis rebuilds himself out in the desert
alongside Rocky and his trainer. In real life,
however, Jordan and Calliet did
things a bit more by the book.
For the 2021 Amazon film "Without Remorse,"
based on the Tom Clancy novel, Jordan had to
develop a more holistic workout plan that even
involved tactical training. The actor was cast
as John Kelly, an elite Navy SEAL whose wife
and family are murdered in a home invasion.
As with "Black Panther," military
training was essential to the character;
Jordan can't just look good, he has to be
able to move and fight with efficiency.
His training regimen included a 12-week course
in weapons training, similar to what real-life
soldiers would receive. Calliet was also concerned
with some aspects of Jordan's physique that don't
get as much attention when he's in the
ring — namely, his legs and cardio. The
two employed a CrossFit-style program utilizing
high-intensity interval training, in addition
to the ten hours a day Jordan would spend in
front of the camera and in weapons training.
Playing larger-than-life characters
can be a double-edged sword. Once
you've hit those heights, it's hard
to come back to earth. After five
years straight of playing nothing but
comic book characters, champion boxers,
and elite soldiers, it was jarring to
see him play a mere mortal once again.
In 2019, Jordan starred in the death row
drama "Just Mercy." The film cast him as
celebrated civil rights attorney Bryan Stevenson,
working to free an innocent man
awaiting execution in 1980s Alabama.
"If we can look at ourselves closely, we
can change this world for the better."
Jordan has a lean figure in his
portrayal of young Stevenson,
dressed in sharp suits that are perhaps
a little too fitted and not boxy enough
to really be from the late '80s. One person less
than thrilled at Jordan's toned-down silhouette,
however, was the real-life Stevenson.
He joked in 2020 when told Jordan,
"'The one area where we don't have to
be authentic is that you don't have to
lose that 'Black Panther,' 'Creed' body
when you play me. You can keep that.'"
"Creed III" arrived in theaters nearly five
years after "Creed II," with its star in a
new phase of his life and now with new
challenges to face as well. For Adonis,
the challenge comes in the form of
a ghost from the past. Specifically,
he has to fight a childhood friend who
spent decades in prison and now wants
a shot at the title from the now-retired champ.
For Jordan, the film marks his directorial debut,
taking the reins from previous franchise
leaders Ryan Coogler and Steven Caple, Jr.
Behind the scenes, the film proved to be a new
challenge for Calliet as well. He had to plan
a workout regimen that could be done while still
allowing Jordan to fulfill his duties as not just
the film's star, but also its director. Training
began four months out from the start of filming,
with Calliet putting his star through the
regimen up to three hours a day, six days a week.
After filming began, however, workouts became
less regular due to the demands of Jordan's
schedule. He and Calliet would do half-hour
bursts of strength training, calisthenics,
or the same kind of high-intensity interval
training they had developed for previous films.
Calliet told Insider that his goal for "Creed
III" was to get Jordan into the best shape he
had ever been for the series. For Jordan, there
were other concerns beyond just getting swole.
The body of Adonis tells a story in the
"Creed" films, just as Stallone transforms
from an unremarkable heavyweight in "Rocky" to
a superhumanly-toned warrior in "Rocky IV". At
this point, Adonis is comfortably retired,
living off the fat of his accomplishments in
the ring and a new generation of fighters
he is promoting. In fact, Jordan went so
far as to describe his physique in a 2023 GQ
interview as similar to a typical dad's body.
While those who rock the dad bod in real life
might scoff at the movie star using their phrase,
his statement provides a good insight into
how Jordan views Adonis at this point in
the franchise. It may also be telling about
how he views himself compared to his co-star
Jonathon Majors, who also trained with
Calliet. Adonis, like Rocky before him,
always has to be the underdog going into
each film's climactic bout. Sometimes,
a dad bod is the perfect
obstacle to have to overcome.
Much of the coverage around Jordan's
transformation over the years has focused
on his workouts and the way different roles
require a different focus. An important part
of his fitness plan that is often overlooked
was his diet. For Jordan and Calliet on "Creed
III," the focus was on lean proteins and
whole foods like rice and vegetables,
with fruit and protein shakes as a snack. While
a diet of turkey and rice might seem extreme,
Calliet is also a firm believer in cheat meals,
which would actually help fill out his muscles.
In their joint interview with GQ, Majors
emphasized how important a steady diet
is to maintaining such impossible
physiques, claiming to eat about
4,000 calories a day when preparing for
the role. He also emphasized an even more
overlooked aspect of fitness: A healthy
sleep schedule. About sleep, he said,
"Sleep hygiene is, like, everything.
You've [Jordan] got great skin, man,
and if you don't sleep your skin won't be
like that. Your muscles won't grow like that."
There is something about playing a boxer
on screen that seems to convince an actor
they could do it in real life. Maybe
it's the months of training required
to look the part of a boxer that makes them
want to take the leap from fiction to fact.
While Jordan has never said
he could be a real fighter,
or even that he wants to, one of
his compatriots has done it for him:
Former cruiserweight Tony Bellew, who
played opponent "Pretty" Ricky Conlan.
Bellew, who famously floored Jordan by accident
while filming the climax of the first movie,
was impressed with the actor's athletic
prowess and work ethic. In a March 2023
interview with Virgin Radio, he claimed
Jordan could be a real thing, saying,
"He would eat a couple of
these YouTubers, no problem."